>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FOX NEWS ALERT.
TENSIONS FLAIRING IN THE MIDDLE
EAST AFTER IRAN SQUEEZED A
BRITISH OIL TANKERS.
WE ARE JOINED BY CONGRESSWOMAN
FROM HAWAII.
SHE IS IN PUERTO RICO.
YOU ARE HEAR PROTESTS IN THE
BACKGROUND.
THE BREAKING NEWS ABOUT IRAN.
WHAT SHOULD BE AMERICA'S
RESPONSE TO THE NEWS TODAY?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL LET'S JUST
RECOGNIZE THAT IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS RIGHT NOW IS
PRECARIOUS AS WE MOVE CLOSER TO
THE BRINK OF WAR WITH IRAN.
THIS HAS TO BE ABOVE POLITICS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT POLITICS.
I LOVE OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
PEOPLE.
I AM CONCERNED WITH THE
DIRECTION WE ARE TAKING AND THE
FAILED STRATEGY THAT TRUMP HAS.
I THINK TRUMP NEEDS TO RECOGNIZE
AT THIS MOMENT, HE NEEDS TO OPEN
UP BACK CHANNELS WITH IRAN AND
GET BACK INTO THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL AND WORK TOWARDS DEESQU
DE-ESCALATIONS OF TENSIONS WITH
IRAN.
WE HAVE TO PUT OUR PEOPLE AT THE
HEAD OF EVERYTHING AND PREVENT
WAR AND HAVING A SAFER COUNTRY
FOR OUR PEOPLE AND THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: AMEN.
I WISH YOU WERE NOT IN SUCH A
SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE SAYING
THAT.
THERE IS NEWS THAT AMERICAN
TROOPS ARE GOING TO SAUDI
ARABIA.
DO YOU THINK THAT MOVE WILL
ESCALATE OR DE-ESCALATE TENSIONS
WITH IRAN?
>> THIS IS DEEPLY CONCERNING IN
SUCH A PERSONAL WAY.
THESE ARE MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN UNIFORM BEING SENT
OUT TO COUNTRIES ACROSS THE
MIDDLE EAST FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE
OF THIS ADMISSION ESCALATING
TENSIONS WITH IRAN.
WE FOR IN ISSUE BECAUSE OF
TRUMP'S FAILED POLICY AND
STRATEGY INFLUENCED BY JOHN
BOLTON AND MIKE POMPEO AND
OTHERS.
TEARING UP THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL
AND ESCALATING CRIPPLING
SANCTIONS AND SENDING MORE U.S.
TROOPS.
WE ARE CLOSER TO THE BRINK OF
WAR.
THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND FOR OUR TROOPS AND TO SPEAK
OF THE DEVASTATION AND THE HUMAN
COST AND THE COST ON TAXPAYERS
THAT WOULD A WAR WITH IRAN WOULD
ENTAIL.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO DO THE RIGHT THING AND PUT
OUR COUNTRY FIRST.
>> Tucker: I HOPE WE WILL DO IT.
TELL US ABOUT THE SHOUTING IN
THE BACKGROUND.
YOU FOR PUERTO RICO.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING THERE AND WHO
IS YELLING?
>> ALL WEEK PEOPLE FROM ACROSS
PUERTO RICO HAVE BEEN GATHERING
BY THE THOUSANDS CALLING FOR THE
RESIGNATION OF THEIR GOVERNOR.
THE CHANTING IS CALLING FOR HIM
TO RESIGN.
RICKY, RESIGN.
I AM HERE IN PUERTO RICO TO
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH MY
FELLOW AMERICANS WHO HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING AND SUFFERING, LIVING
UNDER A CORRUPT GOVERNMENT FOR
FAR TOO LONG.
WE HEARD ACROSS THE HEADLINES
ABOUT THE LEAKED CHATS THAT CAME
FROM THE GOVERNOR WITH
HOMOPHOBIC SLURS AND THREATS.
WHAT IS DRIVING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE
ACROSS PUERTO RICO TO GATHER
TONIGHT IS SOMETHING MUCH BIGGER
THAN WHAT WAS IN THOSE CHATS.
IT SPEAKS TO THE DEEP-SEATED
CORRUPTION THAT PUTS THE RICH AT
THE FOREFRONT RATHER THAN
SERVING THE NEEDS OF THE PUERTO
RICO PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: NO ONE IN WASHINGTON
IS WILLING TO ADMIT THAT.